welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Jason Chaffetz in for Sean
and tonight we begin at the White House
where President Biden is recovering from
a long trip abroad noticeably missing
from Joe's World Tour his son Hunter
wants a fixture on his father's official
visits the Biden family's Bag Man is now
laying low Republicans are poised to
take control of the house and the
administration is in panic mode tonight
the evidence is overwhelming for years
the Biden family enriched themselves by
selling access to the federal government
to sketchy foreign Nationals all over
the world not only did Joe Biden
reportedly participate in these illicit
deals but he also lied about it over and
over again
now in an effort to muddy the upcoming
house probe Biden's allies are planning
a multi-million dollar smear campaign to
personally attack anyone participating
in the house investigation
here now with the very latest Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett and Fox News
contributor Joe Concha gentlemen thank
you so much for joining us tonight on
Hannity uh Joe I want to go to you first
because my former colleague Trey Gowdy
he like to say you know the way the
media treats this they never saw a
republican investigation they ever
thought was justified and they never saw
a democratic investigation they ever
thought should end
uh I mean it's almost predictable isn't
it on how they're going to treat any
investigation into Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden for that matter
oh my I mean Jason for everyone who did
an end zone dance around Democrats only
losing the house by a touchdown instead
of three touchdowns a win is a win in
the end and when the new Congress is
sworn in in two months we're going to
see what a win looks like for the
Republican Party regardless of the
margin many in the media to your point
can downplay this all they like just
like they did the hunter Biden laptop
story in 2020 in calling it Russian
disinformation boy that looks foolish
now doesn't it the hunter Biden story is
a huge story potentially the biggest
story of the Biden presidency that's not
hyperbole because if and this needs to
be proven beyond the shadow of a doubt
given the stakes if the sitting
president of the United States profited
on the Shady deals his son conducted
particularly in China
you know for if he did and by the way
Hunter Biden's business partner Tony
bobolinski has alleged such we may have
a president who is currently compromised
by our biggest adversary yet many in
media are not only missing the courtesy
Gene that so many journalists should
have in any story with this much
evidence courtesy of that laptop from
hell those emails are real everybody's
verified it they seek to dismiss this
and suppress it just like they did in
October of 2020 and look the facts are
the facts and we're going to get to the
facts now that we have a congress that's
actually interested in getting to the
facts Jason
yeah it Greg uh things are going to
change because soon instead of being
just Congressman Jim Jordan he's going
to be chairman uh Jordan and and James
Comer will have the same Privileges and
Honors that I had when I was the
chairman of the oversight committee but
I got to tell you what I think the Big
Challenge out there and the big question
for the Department of Justice will they
with the same veracity uh pursue these
subpoenas
um that are going to be issues by these
two chairmen uh and will they prosecute
people who don't show up or that where
there is uh evidence of criminal
mischief
no I don't think they will I think the
record is well established that Merrick
Garland has been running a protection
racket for Joe and Hunter Biden how else
do you explain a four and a half year
investigation that appears to have gone
nowhere in terms of any charges filed
and as you know as a former member of
Congress any subpoena issued by the
oversight committee or Judiciary is a
meaningless scrap of paper they cannot
enforce it themselves it has to be done
by the Department of Justice over which
Merrick Garland presides and you know so
no mistake about it this is the 31-page
interim report by Republicans on the
oversight committee it is chocked full
of evidence of fraud bribery influence
peddling violations of the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act self-enrichment
and yet there have been no charges I
think what's going to happen is that
mayor Eric Garland will not enforce
these subpoenas and he'll say well I
can't do it because you know our
investigation into Joe and Hunter Biden
is still ongoing but this report makes
it abundantly clear that foreign
governments and entities were paying
tens of millions of dollars to the Biden
family and Hunter Biden's businesses
Romania Kazakhstan Ukraine Russia China
in particular more than a hundred
million dollars flowing into the Biden
coffers and you know it's going to be
very difficult for the oversight
committee to get to the bottom of the
list unless they can get subpoena power
that is enforceable
yeah and along with that not only a
Department of Justice we'll see how they
react because how they treated the
Democrats should be the precedent but
they I I just I can't imagine that
they're going to have the same sort of
speed and and drive that they did uh uh
when Nancy Pelosi had the gavel but Joe
one of the things that's also going to
change and and the the Democrats have
telegraphed this they're starting this
war room they are literally going to
pour millions of dollars to go in and
attack and go after these members of
Congress trying to do their so-called
fact checking and everything in real
time I I mean when I was determined in
the oversight committee I didn't face
that I faced a lot of things but not
this
pre-announced war room where they're
going to go after members of Congress
that's unprecedented in my book
it is completely and social media helps
drive that right you create this
illusion that the American people are
absolutely against any investigation
into the presidency but more importantly
into the president into his brother and
and the real test now Jason is Will ABC
NBC CBS CNN MSNBC PBS and basically
every broadcast news station in this
country will they cover the hunter Biden
hearings with the same Vigor the same
passion that we saw with the January 6
hearings where remember all broadcasting
was preempted as a result of those
hearings that were produced by the way
by a former president of ABC News so
look the same hearings by the way
January 6 did not allow for any
cross-examination in those particular
hearings and it was patently partisan we
all saw that in broad daylight so look
these hearings around Hunter Biden will
be dismissed they'll be mocked they'll
be ridiculed by the very same people
that said you should absolutely
positively take the January 6 hearings
as seriously as a heart attack it's bias
and hypocrisy in broad daylight Jason
but I think the American people given
the evidence once again given all those
things that are on paper all those wire
transfers Bank transfers after a while
when they start to hear this in other
places besides traditional media they'll
be demanding answers because again this
could be a sitting president that is
compromised by the likes of China
Ukraine and all the other countries like
Greg just listed
Greg president Trump spoke less than an
hour ago and he was asking the question
how come there's if they're going to do
a special prosecutor on Donald Trump how
come they're not going to be doing a
special prosecutor uh with the conflicts
of interest that the attorney general
has listened and watch here to what
president Trump just said a few minutes
ago
the corrupt and highly political justice
department just appointed a super
radical left special counsel better
referred to as a special prosecutor to
start the process all over again we
thought it was just about dead Joe Biden
is a corrupt and incompetent political
hack and you take a look at all of the
money that he's taken from foreign
countries and others much of it through
his son Hunter who is a corrupt drug
addict and implementer for his father
where's this special prosecutor by the
way
yeah Greg your reaction to what the
president said
well he's 100 correct it's ludicrous to
the point of being laughable for Mara
Garland to stand there and cite a
conflict of interest that merits the
appointment of a special counsel to
investigate Trump while at the same time
there is a far greater conflict of
interest that demands and it's mandatory
under the special counsel statute for
Garland to appoint a special counsel to
investigate Hunter and Joe Biden what
also concerns me is that you know a
special counsel under the regulations is
supposed to be impartial and outside the
Department of Justice uh this named
special counsel is far from impart
partial and neutral he served in the doj
during two Democrat administrations he's
clearly biased politically and he's
barely out of the Department of Justice
where he spent most of his career so you
know I I am worried that this is shaping
up to be just like the Andrew Weissman
Bob Mueller special counsel partisan
team of prosecutors that are going to go
after Donald Trump with a Vengeance and
not be fair as the special counsel
statute demands
yeah what a coincidence they named a
special prosecutor days after Donald
Trump suggests that he's gonna he
declares that he's going to run for
president and just after the Republicans
gain control of the house so what what a
coincidence uh it it's just it's almost
embarrassing
prosecutor with the presidents he yeah
and you look at this background I think
you're going to hear a lot more about
this so-called Independence of the
special prosecutor and look at his uh
run-ins in his proximity to Lois Lerner
in that investigation that the house was
involved with a lot more to come there
Greg Joe Concha thank you very much for
joining us tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else